Top choice. But first choice would be US.
I also mentioned I'm also applying to Case.
Okay.
You're rock and roll.
Yeah. This is the way.
That's exciting.
Yeah.
Okay. Welcome to the session on...
What happened to the title? It's about RAS, resistance and
combinations, I believe, is the title of the session.
And so I will begin with a brief introduction to the
session, and then we will have four presentations.
And this is not my introductory PowerPoint.
Could you pop up the other one?
That's still not the right one.
It should have introduction on the first slide.
Okay, it looks like I'm giving a chalk talk.
Doctor, there seems to be an issue with the intro
slide.
It is not in the slide deck.
I checked it before, and it looked okay at the speaker's room.
Standby, Doctor. We're working.
Is this it?
No, that's not it.
I apologize, Doctor, but that's what we have.
I will confer with-
Okay
... speaker ready to get the correct slides.
Okay.
I guess I wasn't joking. I am giving a chalk talk.
So,
I'm going to freelance it from here.
So basically, we are
now at the stage where the first RAS inhibitors have now been
approved.
And advancing to now, we now have
at least 73 RAS inhibitors that have entered
clinical evaluation.
And the initial inhibitors were targeting
G12C,
and we now have inhibitors that can target virtually
every RAS mutation. So that's the great
news. The bad news is that the responses
to RAS inhibitors are limited in terms of
the response rate as well as the duration of response, which
means that we are dealing with issues of primary resistance
as well as acquired resistance.
So that is one of the key issues facing
RAS drug discovery,
the identification of resistance mechanisms,
so that we can then leverage that information to then
identify combination strategies
Oh.
To
now...
Okay. Thank you.
Okay. So,
let me just...
This is the evolution of RAS inhibitors into the
clinic. The first one entered 2018,
followed by 2019.
I fast-forward to now, where we have all these inhibitors
under clinical evaluation in 2026.
And just looking at the relative classes of
inhibitors, as you can see, we have inhibitors that target virtually
every RAS mutation.
And pivoting back to the status of clinical evaluation, this is where they
stand. We have two approved, but we have quite a number at Phase 3
and knocking on the door. And we have quite a number of different ones, either
mutation selective,
pan-KRAS or pan-RAS inhibitors.
And at last count, I saw 73 inhibitors that
entered 236 clinical trials, of which about
150 of them are currently recruiting.
And so we also now see many mechanistically distinct
RAS inhibitors,
and one that has certainly been one of the most intriguing one
is one that I'm sure many of you already heard a lot about, which is
daraxasib, which is targeting both wild type
and mutant RAS proteins. And
certainlyThis was suggested PD inhibitor that should never have
happened,
but yet it has happened, and it has defied logic
based on pre-clinical studies, and it is now heading
towards potentially approval this year.
And so basically, we're dealing with many mechanisms of resistance.
Shown here is a summary of the different clinical trials with
G12C inhibitors, looking at objective response rates and
duration of response. And what you can see is the median overall response
rate is about 40%,
and the duration of response is less than 10 months.
So primary and acquired resistance are the issues that we're facing.
A number of studies have began to characterize acquired mechanisms of resistance.
We see that DNA alterations are found in about 50% of patients,
but also non-genetic alterations are seen in another 50%.
We're now beginning to identify through pre-clinical studies,
non-genetic transcriptional mechanisms of resistance.
In terms of the mutations that are being identified in relapsed patients,
this is a summary of G12C mutations, and what you can
see is that majority of these fall within the RAS signaling
network,
and that they're dominated. If you take a closer look, they're
dominated by mutations that activate the MAP kinase
pathway.
Looking at
durinRAS, in terms of the mechanism here, you see
similarities but also differences.
You can see that it is dominated by mutations in the MAP
kinase pathway, but there's also some key differences here, and
perhaps the most striking difference is at the level of RAS.
Whereas the G12C selective inhibitors, there were many
mutations that result in reactivation of RAS
alleles. In contrast, for the pan-RAS activity,
we see no reactivation of RAS, and instead
mutations that prevent effector inhibitor binding.
So we are now facing the task of identifying effective drug
combinations, and this is a snapshot of many of the
combinations that have undergone clinical evaluation.
Some of them are now terminated, some of them are now ongoing.
Of the various combinations that have been effective, perhaps the most promising
and effective one has been in combination of EGFR receptor,
together with RAS, and that has been effective for approval for
colorectal cancer.
So anyway, in this session,
I will lead off and I'll serve as the warm-up act for
the following stars that will be speaking after me.
Aro, who will be the next-gen star.
Sander Massali, who recently gave a talk at ACER-RAS and
anointed the rising star of the field.
And then ending it with Andy Aguirre, who is already a mega-star
in the field.
Okay. So,
let's transition to my other presentation.
So while this is popping up. So
I'm going to address, these are my disclosures.
And so what I'd like to focus on in my presentation
are mechanism of resistance that have been identified experimentally.
I've already mentioned to you mechanisms that have been identified in
patients.
And so I'm going to briefly touch on these
five, one, two, three, four, five combinations that we have been
evaluating at various stages.
And so first, let me talk about TEAD.
This is one that we recently identified,
together with another study, from Ben New and
colleagues, where we determined that the TEAD transcription factor
drove resistance to G12C inhibitors.
We've also had other studies that have identified MEK
ERK as drivers of resistance. And finally, also in
collaboration with Ken Olive in front row here, we also
implicated MYC as also another mechanism driving resistance.
So here we have three transcription factor-based mechanisms.
And so one of the questions we ask is, do these three different
mechanisms of resistance share a distinct
or common mechanism of driving resistance?
So in order to do this, the first thing we did was that since we
had recently identified a KRAS signature that was very different than
the hallmark signature, we decided that we needed to generate
pancreas-specific signatures. We recently established a
MYC signature in pancreatic cancer, and the
bottom line is that the signature is 13-fold more complex than
the hallmark MYC signature. And it also showed us that
ERK-driven transcription is dominated by MYC.
We also then looked to determine a YAP/TEAD
signature, and when we looked at what was available, we found that
of three main signatures that were available, there were
significantly little overlap between these signatures.
We decided we needed to generate our own pancreas-selective signature.
This is the signature we've generated.
Over 2,000 upregulated genes, over 2,000 downregulated
genes. And below, we've compared it to the existing
signatures. As you can see, there is very little overlap
between our signature and existing TEAD signatures.
And instead, we saw more significant overlap actually with
MYC and ERK signatures.So the next thing we did
was we asked if the MYC, RAS, and TED regulated
transcriptomes shared a common set of
genes. In this analysis, we identified nearly over
300 genes that were shared in common between these three
mechanisms of resistance. We then layered this onto
DepMap data to ask the dependency of the genes in that common
core set of genes. And what you can see is that there's an
enrichment of genes that have a high dependency in
pancreatic cancer. So what is in this core of
genes? When we did pathway analysis, we determined
that those genes represented components that were involved in
DNA replication, nucleotide metabolism, and
cell cycle regulation.
So moving on to the second combination that we've been evaluating, PMT5.
This one we also recently published together with a
related study from Kathleen Mulvaney and Bill Sellers.
And in these studies, we determined that combination analysis of
a PMT5 inhibitor together with RAS inhibitors was an effective
therapeutic strategy. And there are now a
number of clinical trials that are evaluating this at the level of patients.
And so the PMT5 inhibitor
we have utilized is BMS-986504.
This is an MTA cooperative one. This is the so-called second
generation PMT5 inhibitors. These are the ones
that are selective for MTAP-deleted cancers, and in
pancreatic cancer, about 20% of pancreatic cancers have
an MTAP deletion.
So this is one study that was published in collaboration with Roddi
Therapeutics, was to show that whereas the PMT5 inhibitor
alone had limited anti-tumor activity,
whereas RAS inhibitor was effective, but the tumors began
to return after 20 days. When you combine it with a PMT5 inhibitor,
you can see it double the time of regression of this
tumor.
So one thing that we have done is to ask questions about mechanisms of
resistance to PMT5 inhibitors. The first thing we
did was we generated cells that were resistant to a RAS inhibitor,
and we found that resistance to RAS inhibitor did not result in
any resistance to a PMT5 inhibitor.
The flip experiment, isolation of PMT5-resistant cells,
these cells retain sensitivity to RAS inhibitors.
What this means is that there are distinct mechanisms that drive resistance
to each of these inhibitors.
And so consequently, it's not surprising that when you do this
combination together, we see a much more long-term durable
response. In these collaboration studies with the Novara stem, this
is combining their G12D
on and off inhibitor together with the BMS
PMT5 inhibitor. And what you can see, very similar trend.
PMT5 inhibitor alone had limited anti-tumor activity.
Here you can see good activity with the
G12D inhibitor, but once again, around day 40, the tumors start to
come back. What you can see is that after 90 days, this combination,
the tumors are still strongly
suppressed.
So looking at resistance, we began to
evaluate how cells might escape the
activity to a PMT5 inhibitor. And the bottom line is that we've
generated PMT5-resistant cell models, and they seem to have
lost their dependency on PMT5.
Okay, so
I just want to highlight that there's some posters from our group that we'll be
discussing in more detail some of the topics that I just
presented. Okay, moving on to the next combination, and that's the
AXL
combination. So we identify AXL in a CRISPR
screen as a gene that increased sensitivity when
loss increased sensitivity to RAS inhibitors.
AXL is a receptor tyrosine kinase that is known to signal
through a variety of cytoplasmic signaling networks.
And so here, when we looked at combination of
AXL together with RAS inhibitor in a CDX model, what you
can see is that the AXL inhibitor alone actually showed very little activity.
Here we can see in this relatively RAS inhibitor-resistant
model, limited activity with the RAS inhibitor, but then
combining the two, you see strong regression of the tumor.
We then looked by IHC analysis to see what was going on at the
level of RAS signaling. And what you can see here is the RAS
inhibitor alone did a good job of suppressing ERK signaling,
and the AXL inhibitor did not do anything.
However, together, there was a more robust suppression of PI3K
signaling and also a more robust suppression of MYC
expression.
Extending this to a syngeneic model, KPC model, we see
basically the same thing. The AXL inhibitor alone did
not show much activity. Here you can see the activity of the RAS
inhibitor. And then in combination, what you can see is nice
regression. So this is in a syngeneic model, so we were able
to ask questions about the impact of this combination on the
immune cell population, and this is a summary of what we found.
We found that whereas RAS stimulated a T cell response,
AXL inhibitor did not
cause such a significant impact on T cells.
But what we see here is that the AXL
inhibitor actually stimulated, together with RAS
inhibitors, a more inflammatory macrophage response.
And also the combination also stimulated a better NK response
as well.So moving on to
the fourth combination here. This is
CLPP. What is CLPP? CLPP is actually
a mitochondrial protease.
And recently, an
activator of this protease,
ONC201, was approved, and so we
have evaluated whether this was an effective strategy for RAS
mutant cancers. And what we have seen is that
this agonist for CLPP
was very active against RAS mutant cancer cell lines as well as
organoids.
And we found that if you make cells null to
CLPP, there's a loss of this activity.
So it was a very CLPP-dependent activity.
This agonist results in significant disruption of
mitochondrial function.
And the other thing that we then looked at was whether there would be
cross-resistance when cells became resistant to a RAS inhibitor.
And what you can see here is that we established
cells that were resistant to RAS inhibitor, and they were
then cross-resistant to other RAS inhibitors.
But then they remained very sensitive to
ONC201.
So, moving on to the last combination, looking
at glutamine metabolism.
So this one also, we will have a short talk
in a session tomorrow by Wen Chang, a post-doc in the
group, who will talk more about this in detail.
So I'll just highlight a few of the observations that he made.
So once again, we looked at existing
KEAP1-NRF2 gene signatures, and we found
that they were lacking. And as a consequence, we generated
our own KEAP2 loss-driven
signature in pancreatic cancer cells.
And this is the signature that we generated.
You can see here our comparison with existing signatures below here,
and you can see that there's a fairly limited overlap between existing
signatures.
So then we compared the KEAP1
loss generated
gene transcription signature, and we asked whether there's any
relationship between these genes and the previous
gene transcriptomes of RAS, MYC,
and TED. And so I previously told you that with RAS,
MYC, and TED, we saw a significant overlap of genes here.
In contrast, KEAP1 loss and NRF2
activation seems to regulate a completely
distinct set of genes in contrast to
these other resistance mechanisms.
So we conclude that the mechanism of resistance due to KEAP1
loss is a completely distinct mechanism compared to the
other mechanisms that I just described.
And so the last thing I'd like to cite about this is that we know that
KEAP1 deficiency resulted in increased
dependency on glutamine. So then we asked the question of
whether a glutamine inhibitor would overcome the
resistance driven by KEAP1 loss. And for
these studies, we used a glutamine antagonist,
DRP-104. And what you can see here is in
collaborative studies that we had with colleagues at NYU,
together with collaborations with Andy and Brian at
Dana-Farber. What you can see here is that
this organoid-generated xenograft
tumor was relatively unresponsive to RAS
inhibitor and the glutamine inhibitor, but the combination resulted in a
more robust suppression of tumor growth.
So in closing, what I'd like to emphasize is that while a
lot of the combinations that are being evaluated are
within the RAS signaling network, which makes sense
because a lot of the resistance mechanisms have been identified there,
I would suggest that perhaps we should also consider more orthogonal
combinations that are distinct. And the rationale behind this is
that the orthogonal approach may be less susceptible to mechanisms
of resistance to RAS, and they retain their sensitivity
even if cells are resistant to a RAS
inhibitor.
So I'll stop there and acknowledge members of the group that have been involved in
these studies.
And then I also want to acknowledge many of the collaborators that we
have with all these different studies.
We could not have been able to do many of these studies without great
collaborators throughout academic as well as industry
collaborators as well. And so I'll end there with these various
conclusions, and the bottom line is targeting orthogonal process
may be an effective therapeutic approach to overcome resistance to
RAS inhibitors.
So I'll end there, and I thank you very much for your attention.
Hey, Channing.
Hey. This is Ariella Henker from UT Southwestern, otherwise known
as Duru Lab PhD student number 17, I
believe.
So anyways, my question is about
the AXL driving resistance. So AXL has been shown to drive
resistance to PI3 kinase inhibitors by
dimerizing with and transactivating EGFR.
So I'm wondering if in addition to the effects on immune
cells, if you looked at EGFR activation there.
So we have not. One of the challenges we faced with
our AXL studies is that when we looked at what is
known about AXL signaling in the literature,
we could not reproduce most of those observations.
And the poor graduate student who was doing these studies struggled for
about a year trying to find a good-Biomarker for
AXL inhibition and nothing that was in the literature
was useful. So at this point, we're a bit puzzled by what
AXL actually does, but it doesn't seem to be consistent
with what is reported in the literature.
So I think at this point, we have to take a step back and try to
understand what AXL really does, at least in the
context of pancreatic cancer.
Thanks.
Thank you for the insightful presentation. Maybe one quick question from me.
For cancer cells or for a cancer patient with, let's say,
G12C or G12D
mutation,
do you recommend the patient to receive
the G12C inhibitor first versus the
pan-RAS, or you should have them both as
the front load and then something else later,
given the mechanism of resistance we know right now?
Okay, so you're asking whether sequential versus concurrent treatment would be the
preferred approach?
Yes.
I think my bias is always to do concurrent, to not
let the train leave the station and then try to catch it after it's left the
station.
Is there any specific reason behind that?
Any specific reason? I think it's just my bias that
it's better to stop something before it happens.
Got it. Thank you.
Rather than try to catch it after you let it
happen.
Said Septi from VCU Massey Cancer Center. Hi, Channing.
Great talk.
I have a question about ERK reactivation.
It seems like no matter what you do, you're going to end up
with ERK reactivation. I wonder if many of these
are also either substrates or indirectly affected by that ERK
reactivation, so both upstream and downstream.
And so the question is, how can we use an ERK
inhibitor, which are known to be very toxic for
obvious reason, but what are your thoughts about using that as an
approach to overcoming resistance to broadly
many of what we see,
and that you showed elegantly? Is it possible at all, and what kind of
inhibitor that would be? An ERK inhibitor, but what?
Yes. So
we know now that many mechanisms of resistance to RAS
inhibitors involve ERK reactivation.
So that a very logical
solution to blocking resistance would be combining
it with an ERK inhibitor.
Unfortunately, we've been involved in two clinical trials now with two different
ERK inhibitors, and toxicity has basically
been a major challenge
in dealing with ERK inhibitors, and we believe that those are
on-target toxicities.
However, I recently heard that there's an ERK inhibitor combination that did
not show toxicity, and maybe it is not a dead issue,
that
we can still target ERK in a non-toxic
way to derail resistance. So I don't think the issue
is dead. I certainly think we need to think more about it, and that
perhaps different strategies for blocking ERK might
be the way to go.
I don't think you need to necessarily-- Maybe this is the solution.
I don't think you need to necessarily have a persistent and
sustained ERK inhibition. I think if you have it combined
with a direct KRAS inhibitor that just
induces that rebound very quickly, if you can time it right with
the right half-life of an ERK inhibitor, maybe that would work.
Just a thought.
Yes. No, I agree with you. I think those are type of strategies that we need to
consider for sure.
I'm sorry. I'm just sort of blinded by the light here. I can't see anything else.
Okay. So, all right. So I'd like to
introduce the next speaker.
And so,
the speaker's also a Next Gen star.
And so this is a significant honor, and it's recognized by
ACR for those young, up and coming investigators.
And so Alvaro will be talking about
his studies that
he is doing in Ken Olive's lab. So take it
away.
Thank you very much.
I want to thank also the organizers and the committee members, not only
for this award, but also for giving me the opportunity to talk
today about my main post-doctoral project, in which I
identify a transcription factor named BMAL2
as a linker between KRAS and hypoxia, and is also involved in
epithelial-mesenchymal transition in pancreatic cancer.
We have no disclosures. Pancreatic cancer is one of the most
lethal disease, particularly because by the time of diagnose, the vast
majority of the patients present an advanced disease, including metastasis.
KRAS is an important driver here. Nearly all patients
have an activating mutations in the KRAS oncogene, which leads to the tumor
initiation and is also involved in tumor evolution.
This is a highly heterogeneous disease and is one of the most, if not the most
hypoxic tumors that we have.
So one of the questions that I had when I joined Dr.
Ken Olive's laboratory was to see whether there were other players involved
in this pancreatic cancer malignancy and evolution.And in order to
answer this question, we first define
key phenotypes important in this event.
The first one will be this tumor initiation, the transition between the
benign precursor spanning IPMN and the actual carcinoma.
We also have tumor progression within the pancreatic carcinoma we have
from low grade to high grade. The association with survival, as well as the
association with the KRAS activity, are also important events to be considered
here. So in order to answer this question, we employ
a systems biology approach called regulatory network
analysis, where we use RNA sequencing profiles
that can help us to measure the activity of regulatory
proteins, transcription factors, co-transcription factors, proteins
that regulate other genes.
Let's imagine for a second that our genome is an orchestra.
The musicians are the genes. They have their
own instrument. They play the music.
The transcription factor, the regulatory protein is, in this case, our
conductor.
The challenge here is that sometimes we don't see the conductor, which means
that in our inexpression profile, we perhaps cannot
see a differential expression in a given transcription factor.
But that doesn't mean that it's not active.
So what we can do is we can see how the music is playing.
The music is here, the transcriptional profile. How we do that?
The conductor is making
all the music playing very smoothly, and by the time we hear
a difference in the music, that is because the
conductor has made a move, and all the musicians has
changed in the playing in a very smooth and in a very coordinated way.
And this is what exactly we do using regulatory network analysis.
We created a map that we call a regulon, with a different downstream
target for a given regulatory protein that are regulated either positively or
negatively. And we use the RNA sequencing profile that,
instead of going gene by gene, we check the expression of the different
genes that will help us see how the
activity of this regulatory protein is.
By the time we have this information, now we can start running
differential protein activity analysis between phenotypes, let's say response
to treatment, resistance, whatever phenotype you can
imagine. And then we can have a list for a given regulatory protein and see
whether it has changed in its activity.
We will find that some of the regulatory proteins don't change, but some
others, they can be repressed, others they can be
hyper-activated. These regulatory proteins that have
change in the activity, they will be nominated as a master
regulators. This is an hypothesis generation tool.
The hypothesis here is that these master regulators are the ones driving this
phenotype.
So we use this regulatory network analysis approach in
our laser capture microdissection dataset that was generated using
more than 200 samples, including pancreatic cancer and
benign precursors, panning and IPMN.
Long story short, laser capture microdissection is a microscope-based
technology that allows you to isolate any particular
region of interest. From now on, I'm going to be focused only
on the epithelial compartment from this dataset.
So we run four independent master regulator analysis using the key
phenotypes that I defined at the beginning: tumor initiation, tumor progression,
association with survival, association with KRAS activity.
We rank all these four analysis, and now VMAL2 was
the top one. It's a transcription factor.
Very interestingly, in our analysis, VMAL2 was the top
regulatory protein associated with KRAS activity.
So perhaps it is doing something in pancreatic cancer.
Let's dig more into details about this relationship.
We took public available datasets where the
researchers uses experimentally manipulated
KRAS, and we take our VMAL2
orchestra. Here, the blue lines are the negative targets,
targets that when VMAL2 is active, are going to be
repressed. Whereas in red lines are the positive target,
target that for which the VMAL2 activity is going to promote its expression.
We can see a very nice correlation between the negative targets being more
expressed when KRAS is off, and the positive targets being more expressed with
KRAS is on, suggesting that KRAS and VMAL2 are in fact
related, and VMAL2 is at downstream
of the KRAS signaling pathway. We not only saw this in pancreatic
cancer, but also in lung adenocarcinoma and in colorectal cancer,
suggesting that this is
more beyond the pancreatic cancer effect.
Now, thanks to the KRAS inhibitors, we can
also validate this experimentally.
We have used the compound RNC7977 from
Revolutions Medicine. This is the analog of the tarox Denosip, which
is one of the key players now in this annual meeting this year.
So I treat different human pancreatic cancer cell lines for
24 hours with this inhibitor and check the activity for
VMAL2. We can see a significant decrease in the VMAL2, not only in
vitro,
but also in vivo. In a KPC single-cell dataset that we
have in the laboratory with mice treated with the same compound
for one week. This is single cell,
only focused on the epithelial malignant cancer cells.
But the question is: What is VMAL2?
If we Google, VMAL2 is basically a circadian rhythm,
the canonical partner of CLOCK. But perhaps it's something else.
It's part of the PAS transcription factor members,
and one of the things that we did was a sequence conservation analysis between
the different PAS family members.And very nicely, we found
out the fact that the BMAL2 was an homologous of
hypoxia-inducible factor, 2-beta and 1-beta, which are
partners of two main players in the hypoxia response, IF
1-alpha and IF 2 alpha. Now, hypoxia,
low levels of oxygen, we know that is highly important in
pancreatic cancer. KRAS is also involved in all these effects,
but the mechanism about how KRAS and hypoxia are
connected is not fully understood.
So what if BMAL2 is also playing a role here?
What we brought was our orchestra.
The BMAL2 is the conductor that, here the red lines means
the positive effect on the direct positive targets
that they also regulate downstream target.
Here, blue lines are the negative effect to direct
negative target that positively regulate other target.
Here in yellow, we have the genes associated with
hypoxia. We found out that around 80% from the signature that we
use, they were somehow dependent, either
directly or indirectly, of the BMAL2 activity.
If we look a little bit more carefully about this image, we can also see that
the positive targets also positively regulate the genes, and the
negative targets also negatively regulate the genes, which
increases our hypothesis about the role of BMAL2 in
hypoxia. Now, let's validate all this computational
analysis. I use different human pancreatic
cancer cell lines for which I either knock it out or
overexpress BMAL2 using the CRISPR technology, and then put the
cells under normoxia or hypoxia. Now, one of
the first thing that can always in the laboratory is look with your eyes and see
what you can see. And one of the things that clearly show
up on my eyes in this particular cell line, but in others
as well, is that the BMAL2 also change morphology.
This particular cell line, PANTU 902, in the controls, is more
epithelial-like. It grow as a colony.
In the BMAL2 knockout, we have the same phenotype.
But in the BMAL2 overexpression, we have a very clear,
more mesenchymal phenotype, which could suggest an
epithelial-mesenchymal transition effect.
In fact, single-nucleus RNA sequencing data from these
cell lines shows that independent on the hypoxia, we see
an increase on the EMT phenotypes when we
overexpress BMAL2. It is also interesting to
point out the fact that the knockout also reduces this EMT
score. And we also observed this phenotype in an
immunofluorescence analysis for E-cadherin and vimentin.
What else we also observe? We also observe that BMAL2 affects cell
proliferation. BMAL2 knockout reduces the proliferation.
BMAL2 overexpression increases the cell proliferation compared
to our control also, regardless the hypoxia.
As well as this also gives effect in the C**n assay
experiments, which could suggest also effects in
more metastasis disease. But what is
the effect under hypoxia? What we found out was,
if we knock out BMAL2 in the cells under hypoxia,
if one alpha cannot be stabilized, and probably some mechanism
of consequences because the cells are still responding to hypoxia,
we have an increase in IF 2 alpha. LDHA and
GAPDH are two of the targets present
here in our regulon, which validate our
computational analysis. And
in order to see whether the effect that we observed before was a direct
effect or was something a consequence on
a different process, we run, in collaboration with Dr.
Yatrix laboratory at the University of Michigan,
co-immunoprecipitation. They overexpress IF 1 alpha in the cells, put the
cells under hypoxia, and the pull-down shows not only the
protein of the IF 1 alpha, the canonical partner of IF 1
alpha, IF 1 beta, sorry, canonical partner of IF 1 alpha,
but also BMAL2, suggesting that there is some complex.
Now we are finishing analyzing the data in
order to figure it out all this complex.
But we also observe
effects in hypoxia metabolism. Metabolomics data in
collaboration with Dr. Costas Lyssiotis, also at the University of
Michigan, we observed that the differential pathway analysis from the
metabolites, from the non-targeting hypoxia
versus the normoxia versus the BMAL2 hypoxia
glycolysis, which is one of the key pathways that
respond to the hypoxia induction, it was the top differential
pathway here. We also proved this in our
laboratory, in collaboration here with Dr.
Christine Sio, that the glycolysis is impaired in the
BMAL2 knockout cells.
Now, finally, what is the effect
of in vivo? So we injected these cell lines orthotopically
in mice, and we observed that there was a benefit
in the survival of this mouse as
compared to the non-targeting, which could open a
new opportunity to
dig more into details the possibilities of therapeutic options for
this BMAL2.
So in summary, what I wanted to show you today was a
concept, regulatory network analysis, as a powerful tool, help us
to identify BMAL2 as the most highly activated
regulatory protein, is upregulated in PDA progression, and
correlated with the KRAS activity.
It contributes
to hypoxia, stabilization of IF 1 alpha, also
affecting IF 2 alpha, related with hypoxia metabolism,
EMT, and delays tumor formation in vivo.
So we think that BMAL2 serves as a KRAS-associated hypoxia responsive
driver in pancreatic cancer malignancy.As I am now
entering in the job market, one of the long-term
studies that I want to also continue is to see what is the role of
BMAL2 in metastasis, as well as I see how BMAL2
also affects tumor plasticity, not only in pancreatic cancer but in
other KRAS-related tumors.
So finally, I want to thank
Ken, as well as Andrea Califano, my mentor and co-mentor in the
postdoc, for an amazing opportunity
to be with them. Also, I want to give a lot of credit to Carlo
Mauer, who generated the laser
capture microdissection
dataset 10 years ago, so pre-single-cell
era.
Also, Melina Chen, Maria Dickson from Christine Sios lab, and
Catherine from Jatrix Sa Lab for all the help with all the
revisions. The paper is now about to be resubmitted.
The funding, and here I include the QR code to the bio
archive that will be updated as soon as we resubmit the paper, but most of
the data that I presented today, you can see it here.
Thank you very much for your attention, and I will be very happy to take any
questions.
Any questions?
It was clean. Clean and clear.
I
have one.
Yes.
You were going first.
So,
you didn't address this question, but do you think
there's any relationship to BMAL2 function with regard to
resistance to RAS inhibitors?
Yes, I think
very preliminary, but I predict that if you
combine BMAL2 with the KRAS
inhibitors, you are going to have an additive
effect.
Two reasons. First, because here
during the meeting, Dr. Cara Imbrogno and others saw that there
was an additive effect when you combine the KRAS inhibitors with
downstream inhibitors. And the second, and also very interesting
point is, you just mentioned the AXL and the combination with the
KRAS. In terms of that BMAL2, AXL is one of the positive
targets of BMAL2. And in fact, in the paper, we also
saw a very nice western showing that.
So I could predict a synergistic effect if we combine
both concepts.
I had a similar question.
And I also noticed that your timing of your
experiments were one week in vivo.
Did you do also longer
analysis and see the regulation of BMAL2, and if
that is correlated with reactivation of signaling or acquisition of
resistance, or more of the dynamics
of expression over time?
You mean in vivo?
In your preclinical models.
No, we haven't checked any resistant mechanism in the
concept of BMAL2. It's a very
interesting question. Perhaps we can take some of the public available data,
including cell lines, and see how BMAL2 is affected.
As far as I know from our single cell,
BMAL2 is going down as I presented here, but it's going
up again in the resistant group. But
yeah, we can also dig more into how all of this is
happening.
Hi, very nice talk. Da Jiang from MD Anderson Cancer Center.
So you must know that in the KPC model, if you knock out HIF-1
alpha, actually that leads to a more progressive phenotype,
right? So you have shorter survival.
But if in your model, that BMAL2 support HIF-1 alpha
stabilization under hypoxia, then how do you reconcile
the conflict between these two sets of data?
So,
BMAL2 is still affecting BMAL2, but it's
doing something else. I'm just presenting, for instance, the
EMT phenotype regardless hypoxia.
So I think that
the fact that we see a delay is because of this affecting
something unrelated with hypoxia, even is helping
preventing this hypoxia response in a certain way.
And your model that doesn't have anything to do with HIF-2 alpha?
We haven't checked
or I
don't have it in my mind,
the HIF-2 alpha in the in vivo. But definitely,
we are now working on doing all the IF,
IFCs on HIF-1 alpha. It's one of the questions that the reviewers
ask us.
Okay, thanks.
Hi, I had a similar question, whether you've had a chance to test the
clinical drug for renal cell carcinoma, which is a HIF-2 alpha inhibitor,
in your models.
No, we haven't done any combinations with other drugs.
It's, of course, something in a to-do list.
I will be happy to do it by the time I start my own lab.
So definitely it's a very nice-- If you are working there, happy to collaborate,
and doing something together.
Any more questions?
Okay, if not, let's thank Ara for a great talk.
Thank you.
Okay, next up, Sandra
Massali.Rewiring under
pressure.
Under pressure. And I started with apologizing for
my voice. Apparently, I didn't develop any
secondary resistance to all the microbes that my kids bring back
home from daycare. Yeah. Thank you so much, and
thanks, Channing, and the organizer for having
me here today. I'm going to present
an overview of what a concern
like mainly adaptive resistance mechanism to
KRAS inhibition. And these are my disclosures.
So I'd like to start
my presentation with this picture, which is a pretty old
but very nice picture that was made more than 10 years
ago. And I was sitting next to the person that was making
this figure back in the days. And I'm pretty happy
to say that today we are in a different situation, we finally were
able to climb up Mount KRAS, and the
landscape that we can see from there is pretty exciting.
And Channing touched about all of the new
opportunities, all these new therapeutics, all the combinations that we
can see on the horizon. So it's
really a very, very exciting time to be a
RAS
lover right now. So let's move more into
the
main topic of this talk.
So we will have more conversation, I think, during the next
talks in this session. But I'd like to point
the spotlight on resistance. Thank you.
On resistance to RAS inhibition. So here we have a very nice
picture that I took from Andy's most recent review,
and
Channing already alluded of many of these
alterations. And I would say that we can really categorize this
knowledge that we are collecting right now
on acquiring the genetic alteration, then we have
transcription dysregulation, and adaptive
resistance, which is what I'm going to be focusing on.
And being honest, there is so much work,
and really nice published data already.
It's a very exploding field right now because we are learning so
much from RAS inhibitors. And I am going to focus
on especially
receptor tyrosine kinases.
It's driven by the specific question. RTKs are targetable.
There is so many ways, and to approve
targeted therapies in multiple cancer types, they are focusing on targeting
RTKs. But the question here is:
how complex is the signaling rewiring when we block
RAS in this different tumor context?
And one example that was mentioned also by Channing, we reported
a few years ago that colorectal cancer is really
driven by EGFR signaling. So even in the presence of
an altered KRAS, in this case, G12C
mutant KRAS, we really need to have concomitant
blockade of the receptor. And these are our patient-derived
models, organoid, and patient-derived xenograft, where we were able to
show that this combination was really
working very well and complete shutting down the proliferation of the cells, and
this is approved right now. And we most recently showed that this might
be true for pancreatic cancer as well, but it's
a bit more complicated. We think that
the synergy with EGFR inhibition in this tumor
context is also RAS mutant allele dependent,
when specifically G12 mutants, they can
retain dependency from RTK EGFR in our signaling.
And therefore, blocking EGFR in those specific
altered alleles works, while Q61 molecule
RAS mutant
are way less sensitive because the RAS signaling
downstream is decoupled from upstream EGFR
activity. And, mm, again, going to reviewing
some very exciting and nice publications been
going on so far, and this is work from Ron DePinho's group.
And here we're moving from EGFR to ER3.
So I'm trying to collect data and explain in
our report her family members mainly in this
presentation. And this is interesting because we are going
not only focusing on the cancer cells, but
also the tumor microenvironment.
And in this very, very nice work, they demonstrated that
cancer-associated fibroblasts are able to secrete neuregulin-1, which
is the ligand for ER3, and this can sustain
growth in these murine PDAC models.
Indeed, when
these tumors are induced, but they are also concomitantly
blocking neuregulin with
YW
compound, which is an antibody against neuregulin, they can
impair the natural growth of these tumors.
And combining with RAS inhibition, it's also effective in this
context because you see the survival of these mice, they are treated with a
combination of
MRTX and YW gives a
survival benefit.
And a very cool kid on the block, it's definitely HER2,
and these are works have been published
relatively recently when combining
blocking RAS MAPK pathway, so in this case, with MEK
inhibitor. And more recently, these are data that were presented the first time
last year at the ACR by Evolution Medicine.
You block RAS signaling, and you get an induction
of HER2 expression, and then you can actually go with an
antibody drug conjugates and have a nice response.
ButThere is one piece of data that,
looking at this graph always give me a lot of headache.
You're probably familiar with this data.
This is the
antibody drug conjugate against HER2 T-DXd.
And in this clinical trial, they were exploring the effectiveness of
this ADC on multiple cancer types.
And almost everywhere where HER2 was highly
expressed, 2+, 3+, they can get a very nice
response in patient everywhere except for pancreatic cancer.
And we don't know why. The payload may be an issue, but
not really, because... Sorry, I want to go back here.
The same
chemotherapeutic agent is also used for colorectal
cancer, but colorectal cancer with HER2 amplification
actually respond very well to T-DXd, so there must be something more
than that. And one thing that we've been working
on in my lab, we are focusing also on ADCs from
a very specific signaling standpoint.
And this is a very simplified way to show
you what are the variables that contributes to ADC efficacy.
Of course, first of all, there is the presence of the target.
I'm not going to say it
necessarily that it has to be overexpressed, but it has to be present.
And then there is internalization and, of course, sensitivity to payload.
But internalization comes with many variables.
And us, in our lab, we are trying to tackle all of these
dynamics because internalization means how fast and how well the
receptor that is bound to the ADC gets internalized and that can release the
payload. And those dynamics depends on
the dimerization of these receptors, which is the
dimerization partner. If this dimerization results in
oligomerization or not, what is the stability in the membrane?
And we have been working on similar approaches already
in the past, and we were able to show that if we can, for
instance, block HER2 using an irreversible
TKI that displays HSP90 and therefore allow
for HER2 internalization, we are able to see
internalization that goes faster.
So this is the assay that we use. It is called FRODO.
So the more red you see, that means that the antibody gets internalized and
degraded. And so we were able to show that this combination
was actually increasing HER2 internalization.
And similarly, most recently, I was honored to
be part of this study as well, and this is in colorectal cancer.
Again, we're using EGFR here, but not to block EGFR signaling.
We're using EGFR to
displace the formation of the heterodimer
HER2/ER3, I'm sorry, through EGFR, and
therefore this will allow for oligomerization and better
internalization and therefore better
efficacy in patient-derived xenograft.
So what are we doing now? We need to make a
very thorough study of this RTK dynamics.
We are starting with characterizing pancreatic cancer cell lines,
and these are the basal expression of these three
receptors.
We are plotting metafluorescent intensity and expression per cell.
So you see EGFR, it's almost always expressed.
This is our positive control. HER2 is expressed in very
low amount, like number of cells, and this is our positive control.
And HER3, it's very variable.
But when we do treat the cells, this is a subset of the models that I
showed you, we can clearly see that the RAS
inhibitor increases the expression of receptors, but not all of them.
EGFR stays steady. You can see it doesn't
change. While HER2, but probably even more ER3, are
dynamically different over time.
And this translate with synergistic
of T-DXd plus RMC in our in vitro model.
But also we are trying to move forward,
not only in the context of 2D cell lines, but in patient-derived
organoids. And
this is now similar to what we did with our in vitro system,
cell line 2D.
You can see that it's very interesting.
All the
models tested here, they cluster together when it comes for
EGFR or ER3 expression. But there is a weird
readout for HER2. It seems that there is a very low amount
of cells in the organoid. So subclonal,
we're still not sure how to define this, that express nice high
level of ER2, but not all of the cells.
And then remember this model because you're going to see in a second, this
seems to be expressing higher level of ER2.
And this is the FRODO assay that I showed you before in the
organoid. And again, as I just said, this one
has a very high level of internalization.
So we serendipitously found in our PDOs
biobank,
a model that has a very high amount of HER2,
and we can see the internalization.
This negative control is
a compound that we use to block the
endosomal pathway.
And interestingly, and this is the last piece of data that I'm going to show you
today, is that when we combine
this internalization assay with
RMC-7977, we're able to actually internalize
HER2 faster or better in all of these
models, including the one that it's alreadyKind of
like overexpressing HER2. So this is to say that there is
room for improvement, and here we are just talking about this
tumor intrinsic mechanism. We are now working to
expand and take into consideration the stroma.
And this is literally work in progress. I was very excited to be here.
I wanted to share it with you about the amazing tumor
organoid biobank that we have at Hopkins allow us
to co-culture this
organoid with the cancer associated fibroblast derived from the same
patients. And we are going to use this approach
to test combination and to allow for
testing internalization dynamics and what would be the
contribution of the stroma in this context.
So stay tuned. I hope next time I'm going to be presenting, you
will see more of this. So with that, I'd like to go through my
conclusions. So I hope I convinced you the
RTK
activity and expression,
they do drive mechanism resistance to RAS inhibition, and we can leverage these
changes to develop rational combination.
The way we do that, it might just not be using the
specific inhibitor, but
take advantage of this increased expression to deliver
cytotoxic payload or other things.
And when it comes to
ADC, it's possible to modulate
signaling with other molecules to improve the
combinatorial efficacy. And better understanding
of internalization dynamics, it's a really important key point,
especially because we're considering pancreatic cancer.
And last but not least, probably top of my
list personally, is clarify the role of the stroma in this
context. So with that, I'd like to
acknowledge and thank all the amazing people in my
lab, especially Santiago Garcia Borrego, who is the
postdoc who is taking care of this
project right now. And as I mentioned during the
presentation, our fabulous collaborators, Jackie Zimmermann,
Richard Burkardt, and their group, they are the
ones that made this fantastic biobank co-culture system,
and we're working together really nicely. We're excited.
And this work is also sponsored and
sustained by AstraZeneca and Breakthrough Cancer.
And it's going to be official tomorrow, but I'd like to also
thank ECR and the Liz Carter Foundation because
for this project, I just got the Liz Carter Foundation ECR Career
Development Award. So thank you so much for believing in me.
And again, thanks everyone. I'm happy to take any questions.
Any questions?
Hi, I'm Chikusa Morizane from National Cancer Center Hospital,
Tokyo, Japan. And thank you for the excellent
presentation. And I am a medical
oncologist, and I'm interested in
such a combination therapy of
KRAS inhibitor and
RTK pathway inhibitor combination.
However, the pan-RAS/KRAS inhibitor is somewhat
relatively high incidence of
side effects, such as
rash or diarrhea. So such
EGFR inhibitor or AHRT inhibitor,
I consider about the
high
rate of the side effect. So is there any
possibility for
sequential use for such a therapy,
or
concurrent use is mandatory? That is my question.
This is a great question, and
my short answer is, I think yes. And
more complex explanation. So going back to these studies that we
did a few years ago in small cell lung cancer, combining with
afatinib. So afatinib, you probably definitely know better
than I do, is not a very easy drug to
handle in patients. It gives much toxicity.
So what we are thinking and what someone was able to
do was to treat the patients with
afatinib for a shorter time and then intervene with the ADC,
because the reason why you need that inhibitor
is just to make sure that the antibody internalize better, so
you don't have to give the inhibitor, the small molecule, continuously.
So I'm not yet sure because we are working
on characterizing all these dynamics in this system, but I think
it would be possible to titrate
and do sequential
treatment in this context too.
Thank you.
I don't see
any.
Question.
So EGFR
or any of the ERB family traffic-
Mm-hmm.
As you've demonstrated, but can we target that
instead of an antibody to promote that?
And this is a question for you as well as for Channing in terms,
we know a lot about trafficking of these and what Rab
and Rho proteins are involved. I was wondering if there's a
way to target those as well.
Yeah, no, this is an excellent question, and I'm 100% with you on that.
When I say that what I like is modulating
signalingTo get the internalization,
it's basically the same, all the other face of the
same
medal. But
I'm not sure in the specific context, because we are
targeting HER2,
or maybe we need to target HER3 and HER3 stabilization on the
membrane that will drag HER2 more inside.
So I think it's a very
wide-open
question right now,
but it's probably key because then you can
maybe repurpose other drugs that were not used
or nobody thought about using those in this context just to
make the
chemo at the very end to work better or whatever payload
we attach to the ADC to work better. So, yeah.
Well, here's why I asked the question.
When we treat cells, the mutant KRAS cells,
pancreatic or lung or colon,
if they have a mutant KRAS and you treat them, say, with an RMC inhibitor,
your choice, or even sotorasib if they have G12C,
what we see is an upregulation not only of ERK but
also EGFR. And I'm talking about the
amount, not only the phosphorylated, but the amount.
If we use an sRNA to, let's say, RAP1, which is known to be
involved in the trafficking of EGFR, we see a
sensitization to RMC-6236 or
sotorasib, depending on the system.
There are ways of modulating those, but they may have side effects,
trafficking.
Yeah.
But it's really interesting the work that you presented
as trying to down-regulate EGFR itself
by means that you use, but also maybe possibly through
trafficking.
I'm 100% with you on that. Thank you.
Want to add anything, Channing? The question was for you too, but okay.
Right.
Okay.
Thank you.
If there are no more questions, thank you, Sandra.
Okay.
Last but not least, Andy Aghari, who's going to talk about mechanisms of resistance
to RAS
inhibition in pancreatic cancer.
Great. Well, thank you very much to the organizers for the opportunity to speak.
Congrats to the other three speakers. Really terrific talks.
Alvaro, congratulations on the Next Gen Stars, and Sandra, really
congrats on the award.
I'm going to talk about mechanisms of resistance to RAS inhibition in
pancreatic cancer. I'm a medical oncologist at Dana-Farber,
and have a lab focused on pancreas cancer and RAS biology.
These are my disclosures.
Most notably, I've worked with Mirati, BMS on a little bit of the work that
I'll show, as well as Revolution Medicines on some preclinical work
in my talk.
So these are the phase one data that had been publicly
released for diraxin rasib. As Channing mentioned, there are now well
over 70 different molecules
in the clinic,
and in development many more targeting RAS in
a number of different diseases. Diraxin rasib is
one of the most advanced in pancreatic cancer.
It's a RAS on multi-selective inhibitor
that targets HRAS, KRAS, and NRAS, both mutant and
wild-type forms,
and Channing nicely summarized it.
And this is in second line pancreatic cancer,
in a setting that patients really have few options.
Responses to chemotherapy
are less than 10%, typically, and progression-free survival in that setting
is only a couple of months with standard of care chemotherapy.
So
response rates in G12X mutant pancreatic cancer in this
setting, 35%. Disease control rates, the number
of patients that are getting stable disease or responses above
90%. So really impressive data in phase one,
and that really led to this randomized controlled trial that made just
gigantic waves
this week with the release of the top-line
data on overall survival, and just really an amazing result.
Near doubling of overall survival, a hazard ratio of
0.4.
In a setting that patients desperately need new therapies, this is real,
meaningful improvement for patients, and
really outstanding data.
Yet at the same time, we know that there are some patients that benefit more than
others, some patients that have deeper responses for longer, some
patients that don't really respond as well.
And so we really need to understand those patients and
understand why some respond and don't respond,
understand the pharmacodynamic efficacy of the drug.
So working with a large group, in fact, funded by Breakthrough Cancer
and the Lustgarten Foundation,
as well as supported through clinical trial
support through Revolution Medicines, and really championed by
a large group of investigators across many institutions
Dana-Farber,
MD Anderson, Memorial Sloan Kettering, Johns Hopkins, and MIT, but really
four clinical sites that enrolled patients to this study.
And really
fundamental support from Revolution Medicines with really Mallika Singh and Clay
Gustafson, and Jan Smith really championing this at
Revolution Medicines. But really embedded in the phase one study to try to
understand patients and response and resistance.
And this is just a schematic that we're biopsying patients
pre-treatment. Now, these are patients who progressed onChemotherapy,
biopsying them pretreatment, two weeks on treatment,
and then ultimately obtaining post-progression biopsies when
possible. And then trying to do as much as we can to understand
response and resistance in these patients.
Looking at these biopsies,
collecting blood and plasma along the way, and serial samples throughout.
And really, I'm just going to show you a few slides on the initial data and
understanding of this. We've taken a deep look at many of these biopsies.
Biopsies are very small, really stringy things that are
really not a lot of material, but what we've learned from many
biopsy studies in the past and this study, is that we can do a lot with them.
One of the first order questions is, histologically, what do these look like?
And we've had a terrific pathology team, really led by Jonathan
Noack and Anuban Maitra, and Andres Diaz Costa.
Looking at these biopsies,
T1, it'll be the pretreatment biopsy, T2 is the on-treatment biopsy,
and we can look at all the cells in these biopsies and look at computational
approaches and machine learning algorithms to identify those cells.
And we can look between pretreatment and on-treatment, what's happening to the
tumor cells and the frequency of tumor cells.
And the
initial question is, can we see that tumor cells are decreasing in the
on-treatment biopsy? And we can clearly see that in this limited number of
pairs to date, 12 that we're showing data from here,
but clearly, we're getting on-treatment efficacy, and
tumor cells are decreasing. We've also looked with a number of spatial
transcriptomic approaches, and this is COSMIC's 1000plex
assay where we can segment individual cells, look at a number of different
signatures. This is a 13 gene progeny
signature for RAS map kinase activity.
The 13 transcripts that were overlapping with the panel that we were looking at.
And you can clearly see in T1 in blue, T2, the on-treatment biopsy
in gold, that clearly a decrease
in pancreatic cancer cells in the on-treatment biopsy.
So we're seeing clear evidence of a pharmacodynamic effect, a decrease in this
RAS map kinase signaling pathway.
When you compare that to normal hepatocytes that also come
along for the ride in the biopsy, you can see a couple of things.
One, that the level of RAS signaling overall in those hepatocytes is
lower than in the pancreatic cancer cells, which have an activating
oncogenic RAS mutation.
And moreover, the degree of decrease in those normal
hepatocytes is less, and I think that speaks perhaps to some of the therapeutic
window that the activity in
the G12D on state oncogenic form of RAS
is accounting for this dramatic decrease and perhaps less so in the wild
type RAS in those hepatocytes.
Again, another first-order question, the molecular glue, a tricomplex
with
duraxin, RASIP, cyclophilin A and RAS.
What happens to cyclophilin A in the on-treatment biopsy?
And this is,
again, COSMIC's data looking at two patients, patient one
on top, patient two on the bottom, pretreatment biopsy, and on-treatment
biopsy, and cyclophilin A transcript's in green.
And you can see in these two patients, largely preserved
expression of cyclophilin A. You can see across
several different pairs biopsies. There are 15 different pairs.
Preserved
transcript level expression of cyclophilin A.
If you look at other housekeeping genes,
RPL21, and then DUSP6, which is a
downstream transcript of the RAS signaling pathway, you can see that go down.
So evidence that, at least in the on-treatment biopsy, cyclophilin A expression
at an RNA level is maintained. So a lot that we still
need to learn, many other biopsies and a lot of data we're collecting on this and a
deep analysis of these, and other data to really
understand pharmacodynamics, cell state evolution
in these patient biopsies, as well as ultimately mechanisms of
resistance.
But
we've also looked at the Phase I data in collaboration, again, with Revolution
Medicines, looking on their Phase I clinical trial.
These are 44 patients, for which we had ctDNA pretreatment
and post-progression. So not on treatment, but after the patient had started to
progress on the drug. And you can see from that pie chart,
in about 60% of patients, we were able to identify a
putative mechanism resistance in ctDNA.
Conversely, in 40% of patients, we weren't able to identify a mechanism of
resistance. If you look at that a little bit deeper, two-thirds of those patients
that had a potential genetic mechanism of resistance were
mutant RAS amplification. Amplification of the mutant KRAS
allele. So about a third of patients overall
had a mutant KRAS amplification. Again, highlighted schematically here in
red, where we observed alterations in the RAS
signaling pathway, and then most notably,
KRAS mutant amplification. But again,
as many studies have shown, Channing highlighted this in his beginning of his talk,
in many studies, there's a fraction of patients, about 40% to 50% of patients,
where we can account for
resistance in the post-progression sample, largely in ctDNA,
and we're starting to collect on post-progression biopsies to really dig deeper.
But again, suggesting that there are non-genetic mechanisms of progression
in these models. And I'll spend a bit of time in the next few slides
highlighting what we've learned from some preclinical models.
We've extensively used the KRAS mutant
genetically engineered mouse models, the KC or KPC.
So they have KRAS G12D. This is David Tuveson's, Suneil
Hingerani's allele. LoxP blocks KRAS G12D,
a mutant p53, and then Cre recombinase expressed in the
pancreas.
KRAS Cre model or KRAS p53
and Cre model,
both significant prolongation of survival.
And these are data with MRTX1133, which is a
KRAS G12D inhibitor.
Significant prolongation of survival.
Again, these are mice, not... people.
I put the little mouse in the corner to remind us. I switch people to mice now.
But significant prolongation of survival and significant
responses, antitumor response. In fact, the KPC model, in two-thirds of those
mice, we saw complete responses where the tumors melted away.
Ultimately, they all came back.
The KC model, a little less deep responses, but ultimately
came back. And then we've analyzed those tumors pretty
deeply with whole exome sequencing and RNA sequencing and a number of different
approaches, single-cell RNA sequencing.
What we can say is we don't see mutations in those resistant tumors.
We see amplifications in about half of the mice for KRAS and
MYC
and CDK6. But again, in half of those mice, we don't see
any evidence of a genetic mechanism that we can put our finger again.
Again, sequencing much more deeply with progressing
tumor. And so really we've tried to understand that in greater depth,
and we've looked at single-cell RNA sequencing.
These plots represent vehicle-treated, so kind of the control, not
receiving RAS inhibitor early on, and then at endpoint once the
tumor's progressed. And then two drug-treated time points, three days on
treatment,
and then at resistance, where the tumor's regressed and sometimes
completely, but come back in the same spot and looking at progression.
And we can notice a few things. And again, just to orient you to these plots,
the well-differentiated classical cells, each dot's a cell, are in this corner.
The mesenchymal cells and basal-like cells in this corner.
And up here is this partial EMT, sort of a hybrid state
between those states.
And we can see early on in the drug-treated samples, mesenchymal cells drop
out early and virtually disappear from the tumor.
An enrichment of these well-differentiated epithelial cells.
And ultimately, the tumor rediversifies its cell states with more
mesenchymal states and these partial EMT states.
We can see that with immunostaining, with claudin 18.2 and
other markers of this well-differentiated state.
And we've seen this time and time again in these genetically engineered mouse
models. Essentially, every tumor in these models does this.
It goes through this pruning of mesenchymal states, a classical epithelial
enrichment,
and ultimately a rediversification of cell
states at endpoint. But mice are really one,
and each of these mice is one genotype.
This represents one subtype of pancreas cancer.
We know that there are many distinct molecular subtypes of
pancreas cancer. I put the TCGA co-mutation plot, RAS mutations,
P53, CDKN2A, SMAD4 mutations, ARID1A
mutations. There's significant heterogenated genetic alterations.
We also know that there are two major transcriptional subtypes, a
basal-like subtype, which corresponds to more mesenchymal or squamous
identity in some cases, as well as a more
classical, well-differentiated epithelial phenotype.
The basal-like subtype's terrible prognosis, poor prognosis with
chemotherapy. We and others have actually found that the basal-like subtype
appears to be the more sensitive subtype to RAS inhibition.
Tomas Tumela as well has studied this and nicely shown similar data.
You see a decrease in the basal-like identity on treatment.
And then these are seven PDX models where the orange are the basal-like
PDX models that have much deeper responses.
And so we really wanted to understand this, in particular, this basal classical
identity. So we went to a bank of patient-derived xenograft models
and
sequenced them and found representatives of the different
transcriptional subtypes of pancreas cancer.
Most pancreatic cancer exists here.
This is a UMAP showing just the basal classical score,
either basal-like,
classical, well-differentiated epithelial, or a mixed picture.
But we also had some rarer, highly mesenchymal tumors as
well, and so we chose a representative of that tumor also.
This is the H&E untreated models. You can see some
diversity. Treated those to resistance.
Small tumors up front, 200 cubic millimeters, treated them with
RMC-7977 through short-term treatments
where the tumor had shrunk by 50% by caliper measurements, but
ultimately through response and resistance, and this is an example,
a tumor volume curve where we had regression and then
ultimately progression. And this is the H&E
pretreatment and at resistance. And you can see a lot of preserved
characteristics across the different models, classical, basal, mesenchymal,
basal-like. Some cytologic shift in the models,
but largely preserved identity except for this classical epithelial
model, which really shows a pretty dramatic shift in
mucinous differentiation and really a prominent change
in histology. When we look at this with single-cell RNA
sequencing, a number of different models represented again between
the blue and the orange. Untreated in blue, orange or
yellow, the treated condition, significant shift, both in the
short-term treated as well as the long-term treated.
So profound changes in the transcriptome.
But interestingly, when we look at the RAS MAP kinase signatures,
Channing introduced his RAS signature. This is looking at that signature.
Again, vehicle-treated in the yellow or orange.
The blue colors are short-term
on treatment, responding tumors, as well as progressing tumors.
Still a consistent
suppression of the pathway at resistance across different transcriptional
subtypes.
So despite the fact that these tumors are progressing, they don't have mutations in
the RAS MAP kinase pathway. They have suppressed signaling
pathways, but they're still continuing and
progressing on treatment. We've looked at a number of
signatures. We're still really dissecting out what the mechanism of this
resistance is. But interestingly, there's a secretory epithelial
program that we've observed, again, consistent with this sort of
classical, well-differentiated phenotype, both in the basal and classical model,
not in the mesenchymal model. That mesenchymal model continues to look poorly
differentiated and mesenchymal in character.But there are clear
markers of cell state, including MUC1 as an example,
in both the classical and basal-like conditions.
Again, short-term and long-term treated increased expression of MUC1,
but as well, in addition, in the mesenchymal model.
So there is clear evidence that there's a conserved signaling pathway
to these
classical or mucins and epithelial differentiation, even in
the most poorly differentiated models.
So just to summarize where we're at, we know that
these tumors are heterogeneous, a mixture of different cell states, and it's
clearly to think about targeting these preexisting states.
PRMT5 inhibition in RAS is one good example of two orthogonal
therapies targeting distinct genetic alterations that may get at this
heterogeneity. We know that there's a pruning out of cell states
during response, and that may provide a real opportunity to target
these tumors.
And then at resistance, they're heterogeneous and diverse, but there may be some
core programs that are still preserved
across different subtypes that are worth targeting.
This sort of epithelial and secretory epithelial program may be one
example of that. We know we need combination therapies, suppress the
pathway maximally, bring in other cytotoxic agents
to target the pathway, and ultimately bring in the immune system and move
those combinations earlier. And I'll just end with a couple of
slides. We know chemotherapy is highly attractive as a combination
therapy, one, for practical reasons.
It's the standard of care in diseases like pancreas cancer.
There's precedent in other diseases for the combination, but there's clear
preclinical efficacy and now clinical efficacy, and Brian Wolpin is going to update
these data tomorrow in a presentation.
This is a Phase 1 diraxin, rasofgem, nab-paclitaxel with a really
impressive response rate and disease control rate on the basis of that
randomized control trial ongoing.
And Sandra talked about targeted chemotherapy with an
antibody drug conjugate. We've also looked at that using a MUC1C
targeting, so the C-terminal aspect of MUC1.
In collaboration with Don Keefe, made models where we can show that RAS
induces MUC1C by flow cytometry up
top and in in vitro assays is sensitive to a MUC1C ADC
that's available through the NCI NEXT program.
Made resistant models and shown that MUC1C goes up dramatically in these
resistant models.
And then in these resistant models in xenograft,
MUC1C is effective at pretty significant
tumor growth inhibition and ultimately regressions.
So this and other approaches may be attractive either in combination or even to
follow on post-progression where there are these markers that may be upregulated.
So just to summarize, RAS inhibitors showing efficacy in the clinic.
Resistance remains a challenge. Clinical data, preclinical
and even clinical, suggests this resistance is heterogeneous.
Some keys to combination therapy, and hopefully really understanding this
biology of response and resistance is going to lead to better
therapies. Lots of people to acknowledge. My lab.
We have a great pancreas center. Brian Wolpin, Jonathan Nowak, key
collaborators there. A number of folks that were really involved in
the breakthrough cancer study and some of the collaborative work,
and then collaborators in the industry as well.
So I don't know if we have time, but I'm happy to take any questions.
Questions for Andy.
Yes, please.
Fascinating talk, Andy.
I have two questions. So, first one, if I do my maths
correctly,
the 36% of
the
patients that received RMC treatment that has
G12D or G12C amplification, do you
exclusively see the mutant allele application or you also see wild type?
Yeah. Great question. In the G12C inhibitor
data, we've pretty much entirely seen the mutant allele.
In that data as well, it's the mutant allele that we can infer from ctDNA.
And I have not seen convincingly a lot of wild type amplification.
There are some data in post cetuximab, KRAS
inhibition with cetuximab, that wild type amplification may occur.
If it's not one-to-one ratio, what do you think is the driving
mechanism to select for the mutant allele amplification?
Because, the tumor cells see both the wild type and the mutant allele
equally, right?
It's sort of like selection because they more like the mutant allele.
Yeah, it's a good question. I think
the amplification of the mutant allele is a
path to overcome the PD
limitations of the drug or overcome what's the maximum tolerated dose.
Amplifying the mutant allele is a way to amplify the
signaling pathway and ultimately become resistant.
Okay. Second question. What do you think those mucin-secreting classical cells
are with regard to
any of the known cell type during PDAC tumor
genesis especially, yeah?
I mean, great question. Complicated topic and discussion, but
the mesenchymal cells, we don't know what drives the
early resistance, but also early responsiveness,
late resistance. Basal-like pancreatic cancer, in general, has been associated with
higher gene dosage of RAS,
and probably a little bit higher RAS signaling, at baseline,
for mechanisms that aren't entirely clear.
But the phenotype of those basal-like cells being more
sensitive has, I think, been substantially validated in a number of models now.
But you have a coincidental amplification of RAS and also
the expansion of the classical cells.
Do you think KRAS is also driving the classical cell state?
Yes, definitely. Those classical cells still respond and
regress in many of those models, but it's definitely a driver
across states.
Thanks.
Ariella Henker from UT Southwestern.
So my question is about the biopsies from patients progressing
on deraxanrasib, where you showed that
PPIA expression has not changed. Have you looked
at mutations in PPIA that may disrupt the
tricomplex or sip a protein expression?
Good question.
And I'm sorry if I wasn't entirely clear, but just to clarify, those are
on-treatment biopsies, not at progression.
Oh, okay.
So in most of those cases, essentially, those are patients still
on drug,
and in most cases, far from progression.
I see.
So it's really looking at adaptation on drug
rather than resistance. And we have not looked at cyclophilin
A
mutations in those samples. And that's something
we'll hope to do down the line and at progression and think through that, but
we haven't.
Thanks.
Another question about the biopsies.
Did you see any early signs of apoptosis, any changes in immune cell subsets?
Yeah. We're just scratching the surface of those data, but we
haven't looked
aggressively at that. The data I showed here were
spatial transcriptomic data with a limited number of transcripts, but that's an
interesting question and certainly worth looking at.
Hi. In the past, there was a lot of
focus on stroma, and we are seeing that the
deraxanrasib really works well in patients.
So where does stroma fit in this picture of resistance?
The architecture of pancreatic cancer remains the same, but we are not
seeing any discussion of penetration or hindrance of the
drug.
Yeah. Great question. Perhaps one of the most commonly asked
questions, is the stroma a barrier to drug penetration?
Tons of great work, including from Ken Olive and others in the audience,
looking at how the stroma may impede
drug permeability. I don't think that's a limitation with RAS inhibition or
deraxanrasib. Sandra and others, and Sandra highlighted in her talk how
the stromal cells may be contributing
ERBB family ligands that could be upregulating signaling in that way.
Clearly, there's a role for the stroma, ECM, and
signaling to the cancer cells as well.
Still really dissecting that.
Hi. John Weitz, UCSD here and
locally. The mucinous differentiation was interesting.
Of course, there's
population and patient cohorts of patients that have IPMN,
and have you looked at
tumor types that are IPMN-derived PDAC or mouse
models, if there's any difference in sensitivities or
are you-
Yeah. Great question. And IPMNs
very often have RAS mutations as well.
So in the
patient-derived xenograft models that we have, they were
derived from primary tumors.
And those models weren't able to retrace, did they come from an IPMN, or did they
come through the more canonical
panin route or pre-invasive route to progression?
Great question. We haven't looked.
Lots of interest in IPMN and RAS inhibition in general.
So I think the field will start to answer those questions over time.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right. Thank you very much.
Okay.
All right. We now close the session and thank you for all the speakers for a
provocative discussion.